COMMITTEE IS CALLED ORDER
WITHOUT LACKING A QUORUM WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- THIS IS THE FIRST
HEARING I BELIEVE IN THIS
BUILDING AND IN THIS ROOM SO
THIS IS VERY EXCITING. I DO WANT
TO LET THE MEMBERS KNOW IT ALL
MAKE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT AGAIN
LATER BEFORE IT HAPPENS THAT IF
YOU LEAVE THIS HEARING ROOM FROM
THE BACK YOU HAVE TO USE YOUR
BADGE TO GET OUT OR YOU WILL SET
OFF THE ALARM. SO I KNOW BOTH OF
YOU WILL REMEMBER IT WILL BE YOU
WE WON'T TELL THE NEXT GROUP
WILL LET SOMEONE DO IT. THE TO
EMBARRASS THEM. US SO LETS YOU
CAN GO OUT THAT WAY WITHOUT
DOING THAT BUT IF YOU LEAVE THE
BACK PLEASE DO USE YOUR BADGE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
EVERYBODY. OF THE HEARING ROOM
IS OPEN TODAY FOR ATTENDANCE FOR
THE HEARING. AND ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A HEARING
IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK
WHILE YOU'RE IN THE BUILDING.
FOR EVERYBODY'S SAFETY. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BY VISITING
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. BUT
NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDER PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED. EVERYBODY IS
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. IT'S VERY
EXCITING. AND YOU CAN TESTIFY IN
PERSON IN THE HEARING ROOM OR BY
USING OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE.
EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO COMMENT.
STARTING WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM. TO USE OUR TELEPHONE
SERVICE THE NUMBER TO CALL IS
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ELEVEN HUNDRED. THAT NUMBER IS
ON OUR WEBSITE AS WELL IN CASE
YOU DIDN'T WRITE IT DOWN. FOR
WITNESSES CALLING INTO THE PHONE
LINE YOU WILL BE PLACED IN A
QUEUE AND TELL YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE TO
MINIMIZE CELL DISRUPTIONS IF YOU
LEAVE YOUR DEVICE ON WE MAY HAVE
TO CUT YOUR MIKE OFF BECAUSE OF
THE DISTURBANCE. FOR SUPPORTING
OPPOSITION PLEASE BE BRIEF AND
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. THAT
MEANS THAT AFTER WE HEAR FROM
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN TO GIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY. REALLY ALL WE NEED IS
YOUR NAME IN ANY ORGANIZATION
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR DON'T
SUPPORT WE WILL CUT YOU OFF
AFTER THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T TAKE
TESTIMONY. AT THAT TIME. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWENTY
NINETY THREE AND OUR STAFF WILL
TRY TO HELP. FINALLY
UNFORTUNATELY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE IN
FLORIDIANS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE TALKING OR
MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF
MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE BILL AND ANY
OTHER DISRUPTIVE ACCESS. TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I
WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS.
IF IT INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP. AND WARNED THEM
THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THIS
HEARING ROOM IN THE BUILDING. I
WILL ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD
THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THIS TRUCK TO CONDUCT.
I MAY TEMPORALLY TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING. IF THE
CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP I WILL
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS AND EXCLUDING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE BUILDING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION
AND WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN OUR
HEARING I THINK WE STILL DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL WAIT TO
CALL ROLL INTO WE DO. I WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES TODAY ON
CONSENT AB NINETEEN FORTY SIX
BOERNER HORVATH ELECTRIC BICYCLE
SAFETY AND TRAINING PROGRAM. AB
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED LOW DRIVER'S
LICENSES BONE MARROW AND BLOOD
STEM CELL REGISTRY. AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO PATTERSON NUMBER.
THIS IS HEADED RUN INCIDENTS. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY ONE PATTERSON
VEHICLES DISTRACTED DRIVING
AWARENESS GRANT. AND AB TWENTY
TO SEVENTY SEYARTO AUTHORIZED
EMERGENCY VEHICLES WE WILL WAIT
TO CALL ROLE I. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR UNTIL WE HAVE I THINK
ONE ONE OR TWO MORE PEOPLE. ONE
MORE PERSON- WE HAVE THREE BILLS
TO DISCUSS TODAY THE FIRST BILL
IS AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX BY MR
GRAYSON. AND HE MAY COME UP WHEN
HE IS READY.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY I THINK
YOU MAY ALSO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE A MIKE BUTTON TO PUSH. OKAY
THEN YOU MAKE THE OVERHEAD AND
PERCENT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX.
WHICH SIMPLY EXPANDS THE BOARD
OF PILOT COMMISSIONERS
AUTHORITY. TO ADJUST AND CREATE
SURCHARGES AND INCLUDE COST. OF
REPAIRING EXISTING PILOT BOATS
OR THE ACQUISITION OF NEW PILOT
BOATS TO MEET EMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS. IMPOSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THE BOARD OF PILOT COMMISSIONERS
FOR THE BAYS OF SAN FRANCISCO
SAN PABLO AND SYSOON IS THE
OVERSIGHT BODY THAT LICENSES.
AND REGULATES THE MARITIME
PILOTS WHO MAKE UP THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS. THE
BOARD'S RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDE
TRAINING LICENSING. AND RATE
RECOMMENDATIONS. CALIFORNIA
COMMERCIAL VESSELS WHICH INCLUDE
PILOT BOATS ARE SET TO CARBON
MACHINES REGULAR CARBON EMISSION
REGULATIONS. WHICH AIM TO REDUCE
HARMFUL EMISSIONS RECENTLY
CARPUS PROPOSED REGULATIONS THAT
WOULD APPLY MORE STRINGENT WAS
REQUIREMENTS TO IN USE AND NEW
VESSELS. THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
CREATE DIFFICULT AND FINANCIAL
BURDENS FOR THE STATE MANDATED
PILOTAGE INFRASTRUCTURE.
COMPOUNDED WITH THE SERIOUS
CHALLENGES THAT THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT
UNDER THE SHIPPING CARE. ARCHER
AND SUPPLIED. AB FIFTY SIX WITH
SIMPLY. THE BOARD TO ADJUST THE
PILOT BOAT SURCHARGE TO INCLUDE
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ACQUISITION OF NEW PILOT BOATS
OR REPOWERING EXISTING BOATS IN
ORDER TO MEET CARBON EMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS. BY AUTHORIZING THE
SURCHARGES THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
PILOT VESSELS ARE ABLE TO MEET
THE PROPOSED CARD REGULATIONS
WHILST CONTRIBUTING TO THE
STATE'S OVERALL EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE. TWO OF
MY WITNESSES THE CHAIR. YES
PLEASE MY TAKE OF VICE PRESIDENT
AND GENERAL COUNSEL OF PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
AND CAPTAIN AND MCINTYRE
BUSINESS DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOTS. THANK YOU
AND YOUR TESTIMONY WILL BE
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES APIECE
PLEASE. AND YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YEAH I
THINK YOU NEED TO PRESS ARE
ABOUT MUCH HAS MY- AT THANK YOU
I CHAIR FRIEDMAN MEMBERS MY
CHECK WITH SORT OF MERCHANTS
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR THIS
LEGISLATION WITH SENSE OF OUR
PILOTS IN THE CRUISE LINE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. AS A
MEMBER GRAYSON POINTED OUT. WE
DO HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN RIGHT NOW. ONE
OF THOSE IS UNFORTUNATELY-
ADEQUATELY- ASSESSING. WHAT OUR
OVERALL COSTS FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THE PILOTAGE
SERVICES WE RECEIVE IN THE BAY
AREA ARE. AND WILL BE. OUT LAST
YEAR- WE WORK WITH MISTER
GRAYSON SENSE GO BAR PILOTS TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THOSE ISSUES
THROUGH SOME SURCHARGES WERE
LIMITED IN SCOPE AND DURATION.
THIS BILL IS AN OUTGROWTH OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. WE HAVE
MORE CONVERSATIONS UNDERWAY WILL
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THOSE OTHER
OPTIONS BUT FOR NOW WHAT IS IN
FRONT OF US IS A CONSENSUS
MEASURE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO SPREAD THE PAYMENTS AND
COSTS OF THE TRANSITION TO
CLEANER FLEETS IN THE- PILOT-
BOATS OWNERSHIP IN CARE- A-
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. WITH MORE
VESSELS TO REDUCE THE INCIDENCE
IN THOSE COSTS THOSE ARE COSTS
THAT WE AS AN INDUSTRY LOOK
FORWARD TO PAYING IN A WAY WHICH
IS A LITTLE BIT MORE RATIONAL.
AND LESS PRESCRIPTIVE AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE CO SPONSORING THIS
MEASURE A TURNOVER DAY CAPTAIN
MCINTYRE SUBSCRIBER OPPOSE TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFICALLY. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS- CAPTAIN AND
MCINTYRE IN THE BUSINESS
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAR PILOTS SOME OF FORMER
MARITIME PILOT OREGON AND-
SERVED ON. A THE OREGON PILOT
COMMISSION FOR TWO TERMS. OF SAN
FRANCISCO BAR PILOT IS A CO
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY SIX AND THAT IS TO
AUTHORIZE THE BOARD OF PILOT
COMMISSIONERS TO ADJUST. THE
PILOT BOTH SURCHARGE TO INCLUDE
COSTS ASSOCIATED. WITH THE
ACQUISITION OF NEW PILOT BOATS
OF THE REPOWERING OF EXISTING
BOTH IN ORDER TO MEET THE NEW
CAR BACK COMMERCIAL HOVERCRAFT-
REQUIREMENTS. UGH WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS OF HIGH IMPORTANCE
TO THAT THE PILOTS GIVEN THE
ROLE THAT WE PLAY IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. IN OUR PILOT BOATS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO PROVIDING A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN. ON DEMAND SERVICE-
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A
YEAR- I'VE SAN FRANCISCO BAR
PILOTS ARE- SUPPORTER OF LOWER
ADMISSIONS- WE SUPPORT GREEN
TECHNOLOGY AND WE ACTUALLY RIGHT
NOW ARE IN THE PROCESS OF A-
CONSTRUCTING- THE COUNTRY'S
FIRST. TIER FOR LOW EMISSION
PILOT VESSEL. HOWEVER THE NEW
CAR BREAK ELATION- GREATLY
ACCELERATE- THE TIME SCHEDULE
THAT WE HAVE TO REPLACE OUR
FLEET WE HAVE A TOTAL OF FIVE
PILOT BOATS- AND THAT
REPLACEMENT MUST ALL OCCUR
BEFORE THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. AT A COST THAT IS EVER
INCREASING RIGHT NOW WE'RE
ESTIMATING THAT COSTS TO BE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. A BECAUSE
OF THE COST IN THE XCELERATED-
SCHEDULE WE BELIEVE THE SOONER
WE CAN COLLECT FUNDS. OFTHE
LAST ECONOMIC SHOCK BECAUSE
THERE IS TO THE SYSTEM AND
THEREFORE WE WOULD ASK YOU. TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION ON FILE SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY TO GIVE ANY
TESTIMONY AGAIN. LIMITED TO JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT NOW HOW DO
WE START CAN WE TURN THEIR MY
CON PLEASE. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LEARN
TABLE AND SEAT REPRESENTING A
CRUISE LINES INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I SEE NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM FOR
TESTIMONY OPERATOR IF YOU ARE
THERE CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE WISHING
TO CALL IN. THEY GIVE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER. YOUR I'M SORRY
WE'RE TALKING OVER APPROVAL
RIGHT NOW. WE'LL TAKE BOTH
TOGETHER OPPOSITION YEAH
APPROVAL RIGHT YOU ARE
REGISTERING YOUR YOUR YOUR- YOUR
SIDE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. IN EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST
WILL TAKE YOUR NAME AND GIVE YOU
YOUR LIFE NUMBER. WILL OPEN UP
YOUR LINE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN
CHEWING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO WE WILL GO TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES.
VICE CHAIR FOR. I THANK YOU- MY
QUESTION A AND A CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
FOUR PILOTS IN THE ROLE YOU PLAY
AND WHEN THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN WITH SUPPLY CHAIN AND
JUST THE COSTS GOING UP- WOULD.
IT BE NECESSARY TO YOU SOMEHOW.
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CARPOOLS AND BY SOME TIME OUT TO
WEAR BECAUSE TO BE A LITTLE MORE
REASONABLE- TO REPLACE THE
FLEET. IS ACT IS THAT ACOSTA IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S UNDER
CONSIDERATION OR A CONVERSATION
. WITH THE BY PILOTS I THAT
CERTAINLY IS A CONVERSATION THAT
THE BAR PILOTS HAVE BEEN HAVING
WITH CARP- IF WE WERE ABLE TO
EXTEND THE REPLACEMENT SCHEDULE
FOR THE CURRENT LIFE OF THE
VESSELS THAT WE HAVE- THAT WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS- EASING
THE TRANSITION INTO INTO THESE
NEW- THESE NEW VESSELS THE
TECHNOLOGY IS. IS VERY NEW-
THERE IS A LOT OF DIFFICULTY
AND- SECURING- SHIPYARD SPACE
IT'S A NEW DESIGN PILOT VESSELS
ARE UNIQUE. NOT SOMETHING YOU
CAN JUST BUY OFF THE SHELF SO
EXTENSIONS- AT CARB ABSOLUTELY-
WOULD WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO US
IN IMPLEMENTING THIS NEW FLEET.
AND AT LAST QUESTION OUT OF
CURIOSITY WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
- YOU UPGRADED TO FLEET IS AS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A MAN OW LONG
DO YOUR VOTE SHOULD ONLY LASSEN.
AND WHERE ARE WE IN THAT TIME
FRAME I IS THE BIG TYPICALLY CAN
LAST- YOU KNOW TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE YEARS- IT WE THE LAST VOTE
I BELIEVE WAS BUILT IN TWO.
THOUSAND NINE- BUT I DON'T HAVE
THAT- IN FRONT OF ME I CAN
CERTAINLY GET THAT NUMBER TO YOU
BUT IT'S A CONTINUAL OF
REPLACEMENT A SCHEDUL THAT WE
DO. A CELEBRITY THAT I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE I TO
THE TO THE AUTHOR THAT MAYBE
SOMEDAY WE MAY END UP IN TO
PAIR. WITH THIS IF THE COST
CONTINUE TO RISE I'M NOT SURE-
FROM- MURPHY STANDPOINT- HOW
LONG IT WOULD TAKE TO- TO YOU-
WHAT WEATHER WAKE UP AT. A GUY
CAL FOR ALL OF THE WHOLE OF THE
RISING COSTS OF THAT MAY BE
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE MADE
DISCUSS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. OF A
POP. SO I'M A PINCH HITTER HERE
I'M JUST. DURING THE TEMPORARY-
THANK HERE BUT I'M ALSO A
MARINER. CAPTAIN AND I'VE
OBSERVED HUNDREDS OF PILOT BOATS
COMING AGAINST US- NAVY SHIPS OR
GOING ALONG SIDE IT SHOULD SAY
SO. I DO- APPRECIATE VICE CHAIR
PHONES. COMMENTS ABOUT SHIPPING
FEES SHIPPING FEES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD HAVE GONE UP SIX TIMES
. SO THIS ADDS EXTRA MONEY ON
BUT MY KEY QUESTION IS WHY
DOESN'T THIS BILL. HELP LONG
BEACH AND SAN DIEGO WHY NOT MAKE
IT. WAIT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S MY QUESTION. PERFORATING
ANSWER WHOEVER WOULD LIKE MAKE A
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- SO
THE SHORT ANSWER IS THAT THE
PILOTS IN LA LONG BEACH-
GOVERNED UNDER A SEPARATE-
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WHETHER
PRIMARILY GOVERNED BY FEDERAL-
PILOTAGE STATUTES AND LICENSING-
SO THE STATE PILOTAGE AND
SERVICES GOES A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT- AND WE ARE PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON THE VERY SPECIFIC
COST FOR SOME CISCO PILOTAGE
VESSELS IN THIS BILL. THE SAME
ISSUE IT DOES APPLY AND SO IN
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL HAS A BILL WITH
RESPECT TO- SOME OF THESE COSTS
WITH RESPECT TO OTHER VESSELS
IMPACTED BY THE CAR COMMERCIAL
HOVERCRAFT RULES BESIDES JUST
THESE VESSELS WERE TALKING
ABOUT- BUT TO VICE CHAIR FONG'S
QUESTION. WE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THESE SURCHARGES IS THE VESSELS
TURN OVER ON THEIR OWN THEY HAVE
A NATURAL SCHEDULE FOR DOING
THEN- THEY DON'T ALL GET CLUMPED
INTO ONE PAYMENT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT NOW IS INSTEAD OF
HAVING THOSE- NATURAL RETIREMENT
IS VESSELS OVER TIME SO THE
SURCHARGES ESSENTIALLY A RETIRED
THEMSELVES OVER TIME- ACTUALLY.
THEY'LL ALL COME DO IT ONCE. SO
WILL HAVE A CONCENTRATED PAYMENT
PERIOD SO INSTEAD OF HAVING-
LOWER FEES OVER TIME WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT ALLOWS US TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
WHOLE LOT OF CONSTRUCTION
OCCURRING AT SAME TIME. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. THANK
YOU CHAIR- AND- PRE PANDEMIC HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN US BUT
MY DISTRICT STAFF AND I KNEW A
BAR PILOTS WHERE BASEBALL IS
TOLD ME THAT IT UNTIL YOU
ACTUALLY GET ON THE VESSELS AND
SEE THE WORK THAT THE BAR
OPPOSED TO IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
DIFFICULT AND INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AS OTHERS MENTIONED.
ADDITIONALLY AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE BAR PILOTS IN THE BAY FIRST
OF ALL THE BAY ITSELF IS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING UP WHEN I
LEARNED- BASED UPON THE
DIFFERENT APPS AND CHANNELS THAT
OF THE BAR PILOTS. ARE FAMILIAR
WITH- BUT ALSO. GOING TO THE
DELTA ALL THE WAY FAR AS THE
PORT STOCKTON. THIS IS HOW FAR
THESE BAR PILOTS ACTUALLY-
OPERATE THESE SHIPS AND SO IT'S
QUITE EXTRAORDINARY AND AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE VERY NARAL CHANNELS
THAT WE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE FOR MANY MANY HUNDREDS OF
MILES IN SOME. CASES AS A FORMER
CHAIR OF THE BAY AREA QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND- NUMBER
BALK ADE SIMILAR TO CARB- AS
REALLY PLAYED. A PUT A HUGE
FOCUS ON EMISSIONS AROUND IN AND
AROUND THE PORTS. AND I THINK
GIVEN AGAIN THE DISTANCES THAT
WERE UP THERE TALKING ABOUT OF
THESE VESSELS AND JUST THE FACT
THAT TURNOVERS COMING THAT IT'S
A GOOD TIME FOR THAT. TRANSITION
TO MEET OUR GREENHOUSE- GAS
EMISSIONS GOALS. WHEN I WENT ON
THE BOAT AND IT WAS NICE IT WAS
DOUBLY WASN'T NEW BUT IT WAS IT
WAS NICE AND I BUT I DO THINK
YOU KNOW AS THEY DO COME. WHAT
THE COMMISSION THIS IS A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY AND I ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT EXTRA COST
WOULD NOT BE MANAGEABLE UNDER
THE CURRENT FEE STRUCTURE AND SO
APPRECIATE OF A SUMMER GRAYSON
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND THE GREAT WORK OF- THE BAR
PILOTS IN THE BAY. I WOULD THAT
LIKE. TO MAKE A MOTION. GOOD
ABOUT. OKAY ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
. OKAY BEFORE WE- VOTE ON THIS
WE HAVE TO GROW AND ESTABLISH
QUORUM SO CAN WE PLEASE- THE
GIRL. FRIEDMAN HERE. FONG HERE
BERMAN BERMAN HERE WILL TELL ME
IN. VOEPEL THE DAILY DAILY HERE
DAVIES DAVIES HERE GIPSON GIPSON
HERE KALRA. OVER HERE LEE. WE
HEAR MEDINA. MEDINA AND NAZARIAN
. WHEN O'DONNELL. DONALD HERE
WARD. WORD WICKS. THANK YOU WELL
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
COMPROMISE BETWEEN THE RATE
PAYERS AND THE RATE SETTERS AND
I'M VERY GLAD TO SEE THE GROUP
COMING TOGETHER- WITH THIS
COMPROMISE AND ALSO VERY HAPPY
TO SEE THAT THERE'S A PATH TO
HAVE COMPLIANT VEHICLES THAT
WILL BE CLEANER AND CONTRIBUTE
TO GOOD AIR QUALITY AND ALL OF
OUR GOALS IN CALIFORNIA SO I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- WE CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE ON THE BILL. AB
TWENTY FIFTY SIX DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. YES
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NOT VOTING
BERMAN BERMAN I FELT. VOEPEL NO
DALY DALY I. EIGHTIES DAVIES I
GIPSON GIPSON I OVER OVER I
MEDINA MEDINA I HE LEE I
NAZARIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL DONALD
I WARD. WARD I WICKS WICKS I.
ELEVEN ONE ELEVEN WHEN THE BILL
IS OUT I WILL REPEAT FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WERE HERE WHEN I
MADE THE FIRST ANNOUNCEMENT THAT
IF YOU ARE GOING TO LEAVE THESE
CHAMBERS BY THE BACK DOOR YOU
MUST USE YOUR THE CARD KEY CARD
OTHERWISE THE ALARM WILL GO OFF.
THE NOW YOU'VE ALL BEEN WARNED.
THANK YOU AND- I'M GOING TO ASK
MR STONE TO COME FORWARD FOR HIS
BILL I KNOW. THINGS AND WHILE
HE'S COMING UP WHY DON'T WE GO
AHEAD AND TAKE ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. HEY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND CORPORAL
CALL PLEASE. I WAS A CONSENT
FRIEDMAN. AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FONG
. FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I WILL
TELL. VOEPEL I DAILY DAILY I
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON GIPSON I
KALRA OVER I LEE. LEE I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I WARD WARD
I WICKS WICKS HI. OKAY WHAT IS
THE VOTE THE FIFTEEN SORRY WHAT
. AND THIRTEEN THIRTEEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED MR
STONE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MADAM
pJOURNEY TO A. B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX STARTED A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR QUITE SOME
TIME IS ENSURING THAT WHEN
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATING
CALIFORNIA COME OUT THEY CAN
HAVE A- VALID. IDENTIFICATION
BECAUSE A THE CHALLENGES OF
PRESENTING A PRISON ID OR OTHER
TYPES OF A VERIFICATIONS WHO'S
REALLY DAUNTING AND WE KNOW THAT
A VALID IDENTIFICATION FOR
SOMEBODY COMING OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY. IS A MAJOR INDICATOR
OR GIVE THEM THE ABILITY HAVE
SUCCESS THEY COULDN'T OTHERWISE
HAVE NOT HAVING AN IDEAS IS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPEDIMENT. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD THOUGH
IN GETTING DRIVER'S LICENSES TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE INSIDE IS
THAT NOT ALL. PEOPLE ON THE
INSIDE. AS THEY COME OUT-
ELIGIBLE FOR DRIVER'S LICENSE
WHEN THIS BODY PASSED DRIVER'S
LICENSES A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
FOR IN DOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS IT
DID NOT CONTEMPLATE A CALIFORNIA
ID. SO NOW SOMEONE WHO DOES NOT
QUALIFY FOR A FEDERAL ID. CANNOT
HAVE A CALIFORNIA ID. UNLESS
THEY GO THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
GETTING A CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S
LICENSE. AB SEVENTY SIXTY SIX IS
A BILL TO CLOSE THAT GAP IT
WOULD MAKE. ELIGIBLE ANYONE TO
GET A CALIFORNIA ID WHO IS NOT
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE FOR DRIVER'S
LICENSE. INCLUDING WITHOUT
REGARD TO DOCUMENTATION STATUS.
A BALLOT IDEA SOMETHING WE TAKE
FOR GRANTED. THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE THEM AND- HAVING THE
ABILITY TO PRESENT OURSELVES
WHETHER IT'S FOR LOAN OR WHETHER
IT'S FOR HOUSING OR WHAT
WHATEVER IT IS IN OUR SOCIETY
AND NOT HAVING AN IDEA IS A IS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPEDIMENT SO THIS
IS WHAT EXPAND TO THE
UNDOCUMENTED DRIVERS LICENSE
PROGRAM THAT'S THERE THE ABILITY
FOR SOMEONE. WITHOUT THE
CONDITION OR OTHERWISE NOT
WILLING OR ABLE TO GET A FULL.
I. D. BLESSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN CHARGE LICENSE
PLUS BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA ID SO THAT THEY ARE
KNOWN TO CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
HAVE THE ABILITY TO LIVE THEIR
LIVES WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
CHANCE OF SUCCESS. WITH ME TODAY
ALSO. IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER WHO HAS AGREED TO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND
I'D LIKE TO WITH YOUR INDULGENCE
MADAM- JUST BANTER ALLOW THE
SEVEN MEMBER TO ALSO GIVE TESTS.
WITH PLEASURE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX THE CALIFORNIA ID'S
FOR ALL ACT. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ENSURING THE BASELINE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR EVERY PERSON LIVING IN
THIS STATE REGARDLESS OF THE
LEGAL STATUS. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
CALIFORNIA APPROVED AB SIXTY
WHICH ALLOWED UNDOCUMENTED
PERSONS TO OBTAIN A DRIVER'S
LICENSE AS A RESULT THE ONLY
STATE ISSUED ID SOMEONE WITH
UNDOCUMENTED STATUS CAN HAVE. IS
A DRIVER'S LICENSE LEAVING A
VULNERABLE PORTION OF THE
POPULATION WHO LACKS ACCESS TO A
CAR OR THE ABILITY TO DRIVE FROM
ANY FORM OF A DID A COMPLETE
IDENTIFICATION. MY COLLEAGUES
AND I JOIN AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX TO HELP ADDRESS A
GLARING GAP IN THE CURRENT
STATUTE ONE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY PREVENTS
WOMEN. DISABLED AND ELDERLY
PEOPLE WITH UNDOCUMENTED STATUS
FROM DOING THINGS EVERY DAY THAT
MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM LIKELY
TAKE FOR GRANTED WITHOUT AN
IDENTIFICATION CARD IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN'T OPEN A BANK
ACCOUNT YOU CAN'T RENT AN
APARTMENT OR HOME. YOU CAN'T
EVEN CAST A HARDER CHECK WITHOUT
AN ID CARD A PARENT WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PICK UP THEIR CHILD'S
PRESCRIPTIONS AT THE LOCAL
PHARMACY. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX
IS NOT ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
LANDLORDS IT IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYONE IN THIS STATE
CAN LEAD A NORMAL LIFE TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR OF WHERE
THEY WERE BORN. THIS BILL WILL
HELP MAKE THAT VISION A REALITY
FOR AROUND ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THEY FACE
OBSTACLES ON A DAILY BASIS.
JOINING US TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF LOTUS CALORIS TO SHARE HER
STORY AND ALISON CAMP HI FROM
THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER WE ALSO JOINED BY RITA
MEDINA- FROM THE COALITION FOR
HUMAN. HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
FOR KEPT LOS ANGELES TWO CHIRLA
WITH HERE AS A TWO. WHICH TO
ANSWER. YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- TO YOUR
MANAGER WE WERE BORDERS CALORIS
WHO'S OUR FIRST WITNESS WAS
HAVING TROUBLE DIALING IN CAN
WE- SEE IF SHE'S AVAILABLE AND
MAKE SURE SHE'S AVAILABLE
ABSOLUTELY OPERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE SEE OF LOTUS CLORIS. IS
ON THE PHONE. WE DID HAVE HER
LINE CONNECTED HOWEVER SHE HAS
SINCE DROPPED. OKAY LOTUS- IF
YOU'RE LISTENING- PERHAPS YOU
COULD DIAL BACK IN- AS ALISON
CALM HE MAY BE. IN TOUCH WITH
HER CAN SHE HELP US FIND HER.
OPERATOR CAN YOU BRING ALISON
CALM HE PLEASE ON TO THE LINE.
THOUSAND COUNTIES I SHOULD BE
OPEN. HELLO I'M HERE AND HAPPY
TO READ AND THE TRANSLATION OF
FLORIDA CAN STATEMENT IF SHE'S
NOT AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY OKAY
THAT'S THAT THAT'S FINE IF SHE
COMES BACK AN OPERATOR YOU CAN
LET HER BACK IN AS WELL SO WE
CAN HEAR THIS IN HER VOICE BUT
WHY DON'T YOU GO AHEAD WITH THE
TRANSLATION. ABSOLUTELY BEFORE
YOU GO ON IF I COULD ASK IF
PALACE IF PARTLY IF LOTUS IS
ONLINE IF YOU COULD PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IF
YOU'VE DIALED IN AS A
PARTICIPANT RATHER THAN A
SPEAKER. AND YET I LOOK AT THAT
POINT THAT LAST. THREE DIFFERENT. I DO NOT HAVEOR QUEUING UP
SO- YOU CAN GO AHEAD ALISON.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON ALL MY
NAME IS ALISON CAMPAIGNING HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX I'LL START WITH THE
TRANSLATION OF LOTUS CALORIC THE
STATEMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LAURA CALL LOTUS I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
GIVE ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA ID
CARDS TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LEGAL
STATUS. I SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH UNDOCUMENTED
STATUS WE DON'T HAVE A WAY TO
IDENTIFY OURSELVES AND OUR
CHILDREN SCHOOLS TO OPEN BANK
ACCOUNT. ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
PICTURE HOUSING AND MUCH MORE.
AT THE MEXICAN I HAVE A CONSULAR
REGISTRATION THAT HAS ALREADY
EXPIRED DO THAT DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. I HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO SECURE AN APPOINTMENT TO
RENEW IT AND IT'S A PROBLEM
BECAUSE I HAVE. NO WAY TO
IDENTIFY MYSELF. YES WE CAN USE
CONTACT ID PASSPORT TO
CORROBORATE OUR IDENTITY.
HOWEVER THIS IS A DANGEROUS
PROCESS FOR US WHO ARE NOT IN
THE UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY. AND
IT STOPPED MANY FAMILIES IN THE
COMMUNITY FROM ASKING FOR HELP
ACCESSING SERVICES AND
PARTICIPATING IN OUR COMMUNITY.
WE ARE AFRAID TO USE OUR
CONSULAR IDEAS OUR PASSPORT TO
IDENTIFY OURSELVES BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT SURE WHO WE ARE
DISPLAYING OUR INFORMATION TO.
HOW THEY WILL REACT OR HOW THEY
WILL TREAT US AND OUR FAMILY.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED A PATH AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX SO WE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT FEAR. THANK YOU. I WILL
GO NOW TO READ MY STATEMENT AND
THE LEGAL PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT
THE END OF IT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL FILL THE GAP FOR
THOSE CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS TO SOME
FORM OF GOVERNMENT ISSUED PHOTO
ID. SOMETHING THAT IS CRITICAL
TO FULL PARTICIPATION IN OUR
COMMUNITY. STARTING IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AT SIXTY NEW DRIVER'S
LICENSES AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT REGARD TO
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THIS BILL IS
THE RESULT OF ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS AND ADVOCACY AND WEATHER
CONTINUES TO BE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY. OVER ONE MILLION
PEOPLE THE VEIL THEMSELVES OF
THIS OPPORTUNITY THAT'S NOT MY
LOVER THE MOST. MARGINALIZE CAL
. CAN'T GET LICENSES THOSE WHO
DO NOT HAVE A CAR OR CAR THAT
COULD PASS INSPECTION. THOSE WHO
DO NOT HAVE CAR INSURANCE FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE A MEDICAL
CONDITION THAT PREVENTS THEM
FROM DRIVING. OR THOSE WHO
SIMPLY DO NOT KNOW HOW TO DRIVE.
THEY ALL REMAIN UNABLE TO ACCESS
THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT ISSUED
PHOTO ID EIGHTY SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX WOULD SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
RIGHT NOW THEY MUST RELY UPON AN
ALTERNATIVE ID IF THEY EVEN HAVE
ACCESS TO ONE SUCH AS A FOREIGN
CONSULAR ID YOUR FOREIGN
PASSPORT. THESE ALTERNATIVE
IDEAS MAY NOT BE UNIVERSALLY
ACCEPTED. AS LORD IT SHARED. IN
THE TRANSLATED STATEMENT I READ
SHE HAS BEEN UNABLE TO RENEW HER
CONCERT HE BECAUSE OF THAT AND
THEN. I WANT TO THANK YOU.
MEMBER FOR PUTTING THIS.
ALLEGEDLY TO ENSURE THAT NO
CALIFORNIA LACK THE BALLOT
GOVERNMENT ISSUED PHOTO ID.
SIMPLY BECAUSE FOR THOSE TWO AND
DOCUMENTED WE HAVE TIED HAVING
AN ID TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE. AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY SIXTY SEVEN
YOU'RE AT SIXTY DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS. TO VERIFY IDENTITY
AND RESIDENTS. EIGHTY SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX ID CARD COULD HAVE A
SIMILAR DISTINGUISHING MARKER
CLARIFYING THAT THEY ARE NOT
VALID FOR FEDERAL PURPOSES. AT
SIXTY WITH A RESOUNDING SUCCESS
TRANSFORMING THE LIVES OF MORE
THAN ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
IT'S PAST AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX
CAN DO THE SAME. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT AND I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU AND
I BELIEVE YOUR NEXT WITNESSES
HERE ONLY IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
SO WE ROLL WAIT UNTIL WE HEAR
FROM THE REST OF THE- COMMITTEE
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION ON FILE.
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY. ON AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX. I DO SEE
SOMEONE COMING UP. THIS IS AB.
SIXTY SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBER MANY STATELY WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX. AND
TO SPEAK ON AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. THE FIRST GO TO LINE
FIFTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HEY
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MANY
MEMBERS- AND JACKIE GONZALO
POLICY DIRECTOR. FOR IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE ADVOCATES CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. WE WILL GO NEXT TO LINE
SIXTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI WE
ARE CHAIRED MEMBERS SELECTED
CONSEJERO- GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER- A PROP
COSPONSORED AND- IN SUPPORT- AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHT. GEN CAMARO THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SIX. THE MANAGER WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU LET ME GO NOW TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS OR ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANYBODY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS. JUST WHEN I THINK THE
AUTHORS FOR BRING THE BILL FORD
AND THINK IT'S GREAT YOU'VE I
KNOW YOU'VE DONE WORK IN THIS
SPACE BEFORE MR STONE WITH A B.
AT IS A CO AUTHOR. MR MEDINA.
YEAH ALSO WANNA THANK THE- GO
OUT- THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IN
THE- BILL FORD AND- ALSO LIKE
TO. ASK TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. GIPSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO ADD MY VOICE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES WHO ASKED TO BE
ADDED- WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE FINISHING THIS WORK
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO ONE IS LEFT OUT NO ONE
IS LEFT BEHIND AND THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY OF FINISH THE WORK
THAT WAS STARTED BY GRANTING
EVERYONE WANTS TO DRIVE ALLIES
TO HAVE DRIVE LIES BUT REALIZING
THAT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
DON'T WANT TO DRIVE. AND WITH A
IDENTIFICATION IT GIVES THEM TO
GIVE THEM UP TO THE WHOLE- AS MR
JONES SAWYER INDICATED- RENTING-
CARS OR WHATEVER THE SITUATION
MAY BE GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY AND
WE WANT TO GIVE- ANYONE AND
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED. AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK
YOU ANNA I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE BUT I HAVE TO GO IN
PRESENTED BILL THEY'VE JUST
FINISHED NATURAL RESOURCES SO
I'M GOING TO TURN THIS OVER. TO
MY- VICE CHAIR BUT I WOULD ALSO
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO DO THAT
AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. ARE
THERE ANY MORE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. ASSENAGON MISTER
SHOWS THAT CLOSE. WE ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. A MAN SEXY MAGICTR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG ADELE FONG NO
BERMAN. BERMAN I VOEPEL NO.
VOEPEL NOW DALY DALY I DAVIS.
DAVIES NOT VOTING GIPSON. GIPSON
I KALRA KALRA I LEE LEE I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I WARD. WARD
WICKS WICKS I. NINE TWO NINE TWO
WILL HOLD THEIR VOTE OPEN IF
THERE ANY ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS. SEVEN OR
GIPSON- AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR.
THESE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME. TO PRESENT THIS BILL IS
BRAND NEW BEAUTIFUL ROLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN TO
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
SEEKS TO EXPAND A REBATE FOR
GRAIN TRANSPORTATION DEVICE.
MAKING THEM MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY
THERE ARE REBATE PROGRAMS FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
SPECIFICALLY FOR E. BIKES BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PROGRAMS AND CAN
ACT L. TO R. ACT AS A LOW
HANGING FRUIT FOR THOSE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD FULL ELECTRIC CAR
VEHICLES. AND EVEN SMALLER
DEVICES CAN COST ANYWHERE
BETWEEN. THREE HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR MORE FOR
MEETING THIS. IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT I REPRESENT WHOM TOP
PRIORITY IS TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE. CLOSE ON THEIR FAMILY'S
BACKS. THIS IS STILL TOO
EXPENSIVE SOMETIMES THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A REBATE PROGRAM
THAT INCLUDES OTHER GREEN
TECHNOLOGY LIKE E. SCOOTERS. E.
SKATEBOARDS AND NEIGHBORHOOD OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES- THESE ARE WE
CALL MANY VEHICLES THAT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS TO GET BACKWARDS AND
FORWARDS- TO THEIR OWN SEPARATE
DESTINATIONS AND JUST EVEN GO TO
THE STORE THIS IS NOT TO
DISCOURAGE ANYONE FROM
PURCHASING A FULL SIZE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE. PEOPLE MY DISTRICT ARE
STILL TAKING TRACK PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THEY'RE STILL
PUTTING I'M IS THAT GOING TO
STARBUCKS THEY ARE STILL-
PUTTING MAKING INSTANT COFFEE
AND PUTTING IT INTO A THERMOS TO
GET TO GO TO WORK OR RIDING
THEIR BIKES AND PUTTING IT ON A
BUS RATHER WE ARE ENCOURAGING
MORE CALIFORNIA'S TO ADOPT LESS
EXPENSIVE. GREEN OPPORTUNITIES
EXPRESS THE LOK INCOME
POPULATIONS THESE DEVICES ARE
ALSO MORE PORTABLE NO ONE
UNDERSCORE PORTABLE IF OWN THEY
CAN BE CHARGED AT HOME. OR IN
SMALLER SPACES ABOUT 70% OF THE
TRIPS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ARE
WITHIN THREE MILES OF A PERSON'S
HOME. THIS IS A DISTANCE TO OF
SO MANY WHO WALKS AND ALSO WHO
TAKES SHORT TRIPS FOR
TRANSPORTATION. AND
TRANSPORTATION COSTS ARE HAVE
THE ARE HEAVILY ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT STILL CONSTITUENTS IN
MY DISTRICTS PAYS WATCHES THIRTY
POINT 5% MORE TRANSPORTATION
EACH YEAR THEN THE REST OF THE
UNITED STATES ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER FOR JOBS. AND GASOLINE IS
STILL TOO HIGH. THESE EXPENSE
TIES COMMUNITIES DOWNS AND
CONTINUE- TO MAKE SURE THAT
RESIDENTS- AGAINST TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN MEET THE
BASIC NEEDS. IN THE COMMUNITY IF
WE WISH TO MEET OUR EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS AS A STATE WE
SET OF FINE FASTER AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
EVEN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO ADOPT GREEN
TECHNOLOGY THIS ISN'T THIS- CAN
ASSIST THEIR EVERYDAY LIVES AND
IT COULD BE DONE NOW. AND RECENT
REPORTS SHOW THAT MICROPLASTIC
TATIAN DEVICES ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN THE
COUNTRY. THEY ARE EVEN
OUTSELLING FULL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO
BUY INTO GREEN TECHNOLOGIES AND
ADOPT ELECTRIC CARS LATER DOWN
THE LINE WHEN THEY CAN AFFORD
THEM. THIS IS THIS WILL LEAD TO
A CLEANER AND GREENER FUTURE FOR
COMMUNITIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WHERE IT CAN BE RECOGNIZED AND A
REALITY AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR
SIX TO INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OWNERSHIP OF ELECTRIC MICRO
MOBILE MOBILITY TRANSPORTATION
BY REMOVING THE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS. FOR EVERY CALIFORNIANS
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THEM JOINING
ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES- ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS JACKIE-
BACHARACH AND ALSO ERIN BOTH
FROM THE SOUTH BAY CITIES CITIES
A COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS I THINK
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE. EXCELLENT
LET'S GO TO THE PHONES- OPERATOR
COMMITTEE HAVE OUR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT ATHLETIC YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SOUTH BAY CITY
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENT WHICH IS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY BETWEEN
LAX AND SUPPORT OF LOS ANGELES
WAS SIXTEEN CITY AND WE'RE
DELIGHTED THAT ASSEMBLYMAN
GIBSON HAS AGREED TO- PUT THIS
BILL FORWARD. WE'VE DONE
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH IN THE SOUTH
BAY ENTITIES THAT ARE TRIPS TO
VERY SHORT WHICH IS A LOT OF
WHAT CALIFORNIA AREAS LIKE OURS
ARE WE ALSO FOUND THAT WE HAVE
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SECOND THIRD AND FOURTH
VEHICLES. IN OUR HOUSEHOLD. WE
WILL WE ARE HOPING THAT WE CAN
HAVE PEOPLE LOOK AT THEIR SECOND
THIRD AND FOURTH VEHICLE AS ONE
WHERE THEY COULD GET SOMETHING
THAT SLOW SPEED THAT CAN HANDLE
ALL OF THEIR LOCAL TRIPS. SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT. ONE
OF THE THINGS WILL BE VEHICLES
WOULD DO IS THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO GO ON YOUR HEARING. THEY
WOULD FREE UP CONGESTION IN A
ROADWAY. DAY WOULD STATE BECAUSE
WE'RE SETTING UP A NETWORK OF
STREETS THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
TRAVEL ON THE STREET. THEY WOULD
BE AN ALTERNATIVE TO A FULL
SPEED CARD THEY BE AFFORDABLE
AND PROBABLY ONE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO STAY WOULD
REALLY HELP CLIMATE CHANGE- THE
MEETING CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE
STATE'S. CLIMATE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE HAVE
REBATES FOR BOTH THE VEHICLES WE
HAVE REBATES FOR BIKE. BUT
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF THE
COMMUNITY OF SENIORS FOR EXAMPLE
AND THOSE. WHO ARE PHYSICALLY
CHALLENGED YOU CAN USE THESE
VEHICLES AND NEIGHBORHOOD
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. OR THERE ARE
EVEN CRITTERS THAT ARE MEANT FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE PHYSICALLY
CHALLENGED OR SENIORS. AND THOSE
PEOPLE COULD USE THESE FOUR FOR
LOW THEIR LOCAL TRIPS. AND GIVE
THEM INDEPENDENCE AND HAVE THEM
AFFORDABLE. WE'RE DEBT THAT YOU-
ALLOW US TO FOCUS ON THIS MARKET
WE CAN GET THE NEW BURGEONING
MARKET THE GAPS. IN OUR SALES
AND WOULD REALLY REDUCE
CONGESTION AND CREATE- AND
AFFORDABLE WAY FOR PEOPLE TO GET
AROUND TO DO MOST OF THEIR
CHIPS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE INTERNET FROM THE CITY
COUNCIL GOVERNMENT- JUST ECHO OF
THE- THAN A GET. SAID MARC AND-
TO DIG DOWN INO THE THIRD A
HUGE MORE OFTEN. AND LOOKING- A
SMALLER BATTERY SIZES- THEY JUST
- HAVE NOT BEEN ADDRESSED IN
TERMS OF THE UNITED STATES-
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES OF
REBATES ON VOTING AT A
IF YOU WILL THE GOLF CART
COMMUNITY. THERE ARE SOME FOUR
HUNDRED IN THE SOUTH BAY MEDIAN
REVIEWED OVER YELLEN'S-
MANUFACTURERS OF THESE COMPANIES
A CALL TO SEE A POTENTIAL FOR
UPWARDS OF TEN THOUSAND IF YOU
WILL VERY VERY SHORT TERM AGAIN.
SMALL MARKET NOW. GROWING MARKET
VERY SOON SO STAY. OF CANAL.
THERE ARE TWO DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
MARK IN OUR AND OUR- AS WELL.
ABOVE ARE BACK WILL ON THE OF
VEHICLES SCOOTERS THE
PORTABILITY IS WITH INVENTION A
SIGNIFICANT AGAIN AT THE AT THE
LOWER END IN TERMS OF COST.
AGAIN WE SEE MORE AND MORE OF
THESE AND I'M MORE MORE OF THESE
ON OUR STREETS AND LOCAL STREETS
IS JACKIE MENTIONED THE CALLING
OF THE DIVINE. PLAN AND WE ARE
NOW IMPLEMENTING WITH OTHER
CITIES A LOCAL TRAVEL NETWORK
SPORTY'S GOING MARKET OF
SUSTAINABLE ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES YOUR SUPPORT- AND THEN
OF THIS BILL. A PASSAGE AND INTO
REALITY WOULDSIGNIFICANT IN
TERMS OF SUSTAINABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY FOR THOSE WHO.
OTHERWISE MIGHT BE- I HAVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR- MOBILITY
OPTIONS HERE IN THE SOUTH BAY.
AND ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE NOT.
ON IS THERE ANY IN THERE HEARING
ROOM WISHING TO. IN SOME OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NONE LET'S GO TO THE PHONES
OPERATE A COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE. AND
TO SPEAK OF SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO IN QUEUED UP. OKAY SO WE'LL
TAKE IT TO THE COMMITTEE WOULD
ANYBODY LIKE TO SPEAK. KALRA
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SUMMER GIPSON FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD OF- THINKING SCOOTERS
THE CAPITAL ON MANY OCCASIONS.
OF BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS I PUT
IT WERE I THINK YOU WE FOCUS A
LOT AND I'M GOING TO HAVE AS
WELL ON ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
NOT OTHER SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY
FOR THAT LAST MILE. WHEN WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BUILT
AROUND THE VEHICLE. AND YOU WERE
I LIVE IN IN SAN JOSE I HAVE TO
WALK OVER A MILE TO THE CLOSEST
BUS STOP. THREE MILES THE
CLOSEST LIGHT RAIL OR CALTRAIN
OR REGIONAL TRAIN SYSTEM AND ARE
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW. THESE
BICYCLES AND OTHER SMALL. YOU
KNOW ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE I HAVE
NO OPTION BUT TO TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SO. SHE DID IT
BUT I KNOW THERE'S ALREADY
MOTION RATHER TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR. OF POSSIBLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYBODY
ELSE COMMITTEE I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
CERTAINLY A SUPPORTER OF ALL
SORTS OF ALTERNATIVE
TRANSPORTATION THAT GIVES PEOPLE
MOBILITY OPTIONS OTHER THAN
THEIR CARS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN IPHON. FOG NOT VOTING
BERMAN BERMAN I VOEPEL. VOEPEL
NOT VOTING DALY DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I GIPSON I GIPSON AYE
KALRA. KALRA I LI LI I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. THIS AREA I
WENT. WHEN NOT VOTING O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I WARD. THANK YOU
WICKS WICKS I. ELEVEN ZERO.
ELEVEN ZERO WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THE
U. S. YOU GIPSON. AMERITECH A
WHAT YOU CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
ABSENT FROM THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FOR CONSENT. IDMS ON CONSENT IN
THIS AREA. NAZARIAN I WENT. A
ITEMS ON CONSENT. WHEN I.
THIRTEEN ZERO. AND FOR THE SAME
MEMBERS WE WILL COMMENCE AFTER
YOU- CALL THE ROLL FOR- FILE
ITEM TO YOU AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX
. FILE ITEM TO AB TWENTY FIFTY
SIX THIS AREA. MISSOURIAN I WENT
. OF WENT NOT VOTING OKAY FINAL
VOTE TWELVE ONE. TWELVE ONE
THANK YOU- FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX CURRENT VOTE
NINE TO THIS AREA. THIS AREA I
WENT. NUMBER SEVEN YEAH. OF WHEN
NO WORD. WARDS HERE CURRENT VOTE. TEN THREE. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MISTER WARD.
ABOUT SIX EIGHT WOULD YOU RE
OPENING THE ROLE FOR- FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR FOR
A MR IS IT. MISTER NAZARIAN.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY
SEVENTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
SIR I HAVE EVAN IS HERE IN DOWN
FOR. YES IT DID YOU WANT TO
CHANGE YOUR- TO NOT VOTING GOT
IT OKAY. SO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TEN ZERO. I THANK YOU MEDICARE.
GET A FILE ITEM SEVEN ABOVE
THESE GARAGE FROM RESTORED-
OKAY- WELL. OKAY FILE ITEM SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN A MULTI SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT FIVE SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX CURRENT VOTE
TEN THREE QUART HI WARD I FINAL
VOTE 11-3 FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE
TEN ZERO. WARD HI WARD I FINAL
VOTE ELEVEN ZERO I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WITH THAT I
BELIEVE THAT INCLUDES THAT SAID
DAYS ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
HEARING.